la donación de mil millones de dosis de
vacunas para los países en desarrollo
que deben ser entregadas entre lo que
queda de este 2021 y el 2022 es el gran
anuncio de la cumbre del g7 que esta
tarde bajó su telón aquí en la costa
inglesa en color sin embargo aunque este
es un avance bien importante
proyecciones de la organización mundial
de la salud que estiman que se requieren
por son por lo menos 11 mil millones de
dosis para vacunar el 70 por ciento de
la población
de otro lado del g7 también se ha
comprometido con recursos para la
recuperación de la economía mundial para
crear nuevos puestos de trabajo para que
la economía sea más sostenible con el
medio ambiente y también prevenir
posibles nuevas pandemias invirtiendo en
ciencia teniendo presentes las alertas
tempranas para evitar que posibles
nuevas enfermedades se conviertan en
estas pandemias y también bajar a máximo
100 días el tiempo máximo para poder
desarrollar vacunas pero también el 17
se ha comprometido con
cursos para la educación de millones de
niños y de niñas en todo el mundo para
cortar con este ciclo de pobreza también
el g7 se ha comprometido con importantes
anuncios en cambio climático acabar el
uso del carbón proteger especies y mares
para el 2030 también bajar las emisiones
para 2050 y hacer más inversiones en
infraestructura para así acortar la
influencia que está teniendo la china en
países en desarrollo de otro lado el
presidente joe biden terminó la primera
etapa de su gira por europa aquí en el
reino unido con una visita a una
audiencia privada con la reina isabel
posteriormente yo vaivén atenderá a la
cumbre de la otan mañana en bruselas en
bélgica y este miércoles se reunirá en
suiza en ginebra con el presidente
vladimir putin intenta entonces yo
vaivén recuperar este terreno y esa
importancia de eeuu en el mundo